au-delà de l'urgence
j'entends prendre au nom de la france
plusieurs initiatives en lien étroit
avec les autres états européens et nos
alliés notre action visera à continuer
de lutter activement contre le
terrorisme islamiste sous toutes ses
formes des groupes terroristes sont
présents en afghanistan et chercheront à
tirer profit de la déstabilisation le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
devra donc apporter une réponse
responsable et unis j'ai échangé sur ce
point avec le premier ministre johnson
et nous prendrons des initiatives
communes dans les prochaines heures le
retour de la stabilité passera par une
telle action politique et diplomatique
au sein du conseil de sécurité
l'afghanistan ne doit pas redevenir le
sanctuaire du terrorisme qu'il a été
c'est un enjeu pour la paix la stabilité
internationale contre un ennemi commun
le terrorisme et ceux qui le soutiennent